-Come on!
-It is so good to see you.
They love you. We love you.
Jon Hamm is in the house.
-I feel the love.
-You feel it, right?
-You have to feel the love.
-I very much do.
-I have so much
to talk to you about.
I know --
The St. Louis Blues, okay?
You're a St. Louis sports fan.
-Game 5 tonight -- exciting.
Exciting stuff.
We'll see what happens.
-But I have to talk to you about
their game a few weeks ago.
They were down 2-0, right?
-Yeah, yeah. It happens.
-Yeah. And you entered
the broadcast booth.
-I came up to see some
friends in the broadcast booth,
John Kelly and Darren Pang.
They invited me up to come
switch a little mojo around.
-Yeah. They're down 2-zip, okay?
Let's take a look at
what happened.
-The shot. And they score!
Jon Hamm is in our booth,
and just like that, his boy,
Barbashev, sets up the goal.
And it's in! My goodness!
The magic of Jon Hamm
in the booth strikes again.
And he just scored!
[ Laughter ]
You have done it again!
-You can't write this.
-And another goal by
Perron and the Blues!
-I literally can't leave
at this point.
-You can't.
-They scored four goals!
-Four!
-In six minutes.
Four goals in six minutes,
which is unheard of.
-That was crazy.
Yeah, it was a very --
It was so weird.
Like, you couldn't write that.
It was just crazy.
-Was it -- Every name you
were saying, they were --
-That person would then score.
It was like -- It was
the weirdest experience
I've ever had in a hockey rink.
-Ever, right?
-Yeah.
-Well, now the Blues
are in the playoffs.
They want you for every game?
-Yeah. There's a game tonight.
I actually have to leave here,
and fly right --
I fly right to the booth.
-Yeah. Congrats on that.
That was just such a cool --
-That was very fun.
-Only in Jon Hamm's world.
That's so cool.
But you were in the --
You were just in one of
the coolest things a
human could do.
You were in George Harrison's
video for "My Sweet Lord."
-That was very cool, yes.
-How did you get
involved with that?
-Lance Bangs, who's a really
wonderful director --
He's directed "Jackass"
and a bunch of music videos
here and there.
Kind of one of those guys
had asked me --
told me that Dhani Harrison,
George's son,
was a fan of mine,
and would I be interested in
being in the music video
they're making for
the 50th anniversary
of the release of that song?
And I was like,
"Well, just so happens
George Harrison's
my favorite Beatle,
and 'My Sweet Lord' is one of my
favorite songs of all time."
And I was like,
"Yes, absolutely.
I'd love to do that."
And I, you know,
shot it on my phone.
It was during, like, lockdown
and COVID and everything,
so we all kind of
had to do it ourselves,
but it was -- It was amazing.
-I mean, I don't know.
I know you're a big Beatles fan,
but now you're in
the official music video.
-I know. It's crazy.
-Yeah.
-It's crazy.
-Is there a rumor that
I heard that Paul McCartney
was going to be in "Mad Men"?
Did I make that up?
-It would have been hard to have
the actual Paul McCartney
in "Mad Men,"
'cause the real Paul McCartney
was like 26 years old
during "Mad Men,"
so it would have been an odd --
-[ As McCartney ] Well,
I wouldn't be playing meself.
-[ As McCartney ] I'd have to
play some sort of
advertising genius.
-A genius. I know.
-Something like that.
What are you doing, Don Draper?"
More, man.
-Don Draper, put it on record.
-Let your mind go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Normal voice ] Come on!
That would've been great!
Is there any truth
to that story or not?
-Not that I know of.
-Not that you know of.
-I mean, maybe
he was considering it.
And certainly not
after that impression.
-No, no, no. Of course not.
Let's talk about
"Top Gun: Maverick."
-Let's!
-Last time you were here --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Last time you were here,
you described it as
"the movie
version of a high five."
-Yeah, a visual high five.
-Yeah.
-It really is.
-And it --
-In fact, we might break the
record this weekend
for most high fives
in a weekend.
-We had a screening,
we went to it here,
and everyone was screaming,
standing up, crying, laughing.
It's just a giant, awesome
summer movie that you want.
It's a popcorn movie.
It is a family movie.
It is friends movie.
It is everything you could want.
And you miss going to theaters.
-That's it.
It's a welcome back
to the movies.
You know, and it's, like,
you get to see it --
It's only released in theaters.
It's not on
a streaming platform.
You can't watch it
on your phone -- legally.
-Of course not.
Yeah, no one brought --
-You know, it's in Dolby and 4K
and all of the stuff.
-The sound is intense.
The seats vibrate
when the jets take off.
And you know what it is, too?
-You pay for a whole seat.
-Yes, that's true.
-But you're only going to use
the edge of it.
-Oh!
Whew!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, someone picks up that line
and puts that somewhere,
that'll be the best thing that
ever happened to you.
-Well...
-But you know what
I was going to say,
is how much respect
you have for our
service-men and -women.
-It was impressive.
Getting the chance to
make this movie,
we shot the majority of it in
North Island Naval Base
in San Diego, California,
Coronado Island,
and we shot a lot of it on
the USS Theodore Roosevelt,
"America's Big Stick,"
which is a
working aircraft carrier,
which is 10 stories high
and about a city block long.
5,500 sailors on it, 75 to 80
aircraft at any one time,
two working nuclear reactors.
And to see the -- I asked
the guy --
the captain of the ship --
I said, "What's the range?"
He goes, "We can go forever."
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "Oh, okay."
-You're like,
"I'm an actor," yeah.
-"Good to know," yeah.
"Where's the off,
and how do I not touch anything
that's going to explode?"
-Yeah.
-But it is impressive to see
the sacrifices that
the service-men and -women
go through every day,
and just to keep us safe.
It's an impressive thing,
and the movie is very much a
love letter to that, too.
-Yeah, so thankful to everyone
out there in our armed forces.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fleet Week. It's Fleet Week.
-And it's Fleet Week
here in New York.
I know you did press
everywhere for this movie.
It's a giant movie.
It's a global --
-Global.
-It's a global movie.
Everyone everywhere
is watching it this weekend.
You went and you met the royals.
-Some royals.
-And have you ever met --
-Not the Kansas City Royals.
-No, this is --
-A very different kind.
-You actually went to England.
-England. London, England.
We met Kate and William, the
Duke and Duchess of Cambridge.
-Yes.
-There are some guidelines
that are not so much guidelines,
but hard-and-fast rules
that you are made to follow
when you meet the royalty.
-Like you bow.
-There's a bow involved.
If you're a lady,
you may bow or curtsy.
-Yep. I'm sure Tom Cruise
knows how to do all this.
-Tom's, like, got it all
on lock, of course.
-He's like,
"Yeah, I've done this.
Yeah, I've met
the queen before, yeah.
Let me text her before we go."
It's like, "I'm coming over."
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
-"HMH. How you doin'?
Elizabeth Regina Deuce."
But it was
a very cool experience.
They couldn't be nicer.
Prince William had --
It was black tie,
so we're all in tuxedos.
And Prince William had on his
tuxedo shoes, embroidered F-18s.
-Wow!
-Very cool
"Top Gun" tuxedo shoes.
-That's very cool.
-That means you've made it.
So I no longer
worry about the prince.
I feel like he's made it.
He's got it.
-Yeah, he's made it, yeah.
Did everyone follow
the directions?
-Pretty much.
I mean, I think there
might have been
a few breaches of etiquette.
Did you have something in mind?
-I heard a story that
maybe Miles Teller
was kind of freaking out,
because --
-He geeked out a little
on Prince William's eyes.
I remember coming back
afterwards.
He was like, "They're so blue.
I got lost in his eyes."
I was like, "Okay.
I didn't think we were allowed
to look at him in the eye,
but alright."
-You just bow and you move on.
-You bow and you move on, man.
-But he told him
that he loved his eyes?
-Yeah.
I was like, "You told the guy
you feel in love,
like, you got lost in his eyes?"
He goes, "I think. I don't know.
I've lost my mind."
-I heard this story,
and then we found the photo.
And I'm not kidding,
I think this is the moment that
Miles Teller got lost in
Prince William's eyes.
Take a look at this.
I'm getting lost in his eyes,
as well.
-So's Jen Connelly, too.
Everybody.
-Everyone's into his eyes.
-Everyone wants a piece.
-Oh, gosh, she was great in
the movie, as well.
Can you tell everyone
who you play in the film?
-I play kind of the boss.
In fact, my official title is
Vice Admiral
Beau "Cyclone" Simpson.
-Cyclone.
-Cyclone is my call sign.
Former Top Gun graduate, current
air boss of the Pacific Fleet.
And so I kind of run all of
the aircraft on the big carrier
when the big mission comes down.
And I have to set some
rules and regulations, Jimmy,
and I don't like people
that break rules.
-That's right.
-So when I run up against a guy
whose name
is literally Maverick...
-Wow.
He's gonna get the Cyclone.
-...a little of this.
-He's gonna get the Cyclone.
-A little buttin' heads.
He's gonna have to
answer to Cyclone.
-Yeah. Get ready
for everyone to be, like,
yelling at you, "Cyclone!"
-"Cyclone, baby!"
-I mean, come on.
You were so good in this, bud.
-The really cool thing about
my call sign is that
I actually have an emoji.
There's an emoji
that's a little tornado,
so I can now sign off
with an emoji.
-Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about.
You told me it was good.
It came out. It is beyond good.
You were very humble.
You didn't oversell it at all.
You were fantastic.
-I'm so glad you liked it.
-The movie is great.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Jon Hamm and Tom Cruise
in "Top Gun: Maverick."
Take a look at this.
-Captain Pete
"Maverick" Mitchell.
Your reputation precedes you.
-Thank you, sir.
-Wasn't a compliment.
I'm Admiral Beau Simpson.
I'm the air boss.
I believe you know
Admiral Bates.
-Warlock, sir.
I must admit, I wasn't expecting
an invitation back.
-They're called orders,
Maverick.
You two have
something in common.
Cyclone here was
first in his class back in '88.
-Actually, sir,
I finished second.
Just want to
manage the expectations.
-Yeah, exactly right. Come on.
That's Jon Hamm, everybody.
"Top Gun: Maverick"
hits theaters, Dolby Cinema,
and IMAX this Friday.
Go see it in IMAX.